what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really cool news about the
Thunderbolts the villain of the
Thunderbolts century and Captain America
4 and the new Avengers for those of you
for the fans who have been waiting for
Century to make his way into the MCU it
sounds like the story they have for the
century is going to be pretty dang good
it also sounds like a lot is going to be
connected with the Thunderbolts movie
and Captain America New World Order
specifically revolving around Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine and Thunderbolt Ross
who of course is going to now be played
by the one and only Harrison Ford and
speaking of him he recently had a
comment on why he decided to join the
MCU in a recent interview with the
playlist.net here's what they had to say
of course Marvel fans have recently been
celebrating Harrison Ford joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Ford will be
taking over the role of General
Thunderbolt Ross who was played
previously by the late William Hurt the
actor passed away earlier this year many
assumed Ford wouldn't be interested in
joining the MCU however to forward the
answer as to why he would is simple in
which he said hey look I've done a lot
of things I now want to do some of the
things I haven't done well now he
certainly gets that chance as he is now
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and he
is going to be the villain of Captain
America 4. Captain America 4 is actually
going to be about the new Avengers team
going up against Thunderbolt Ross and
Valentina which of course we'll talk
about in just a bit but first the
Thunderbolts and Century I know a lot of
fans really want to know what's going to
happen in this film and like I said the
Thunderbolts will heavily connect to
Captain America a new world order so
let's dive into both also don't forget
about the Marvel Legends giveaway all
you have to do to enter for a chance to
win a Marvel Legends item is subscribe
to the channel and leave a comment on
our videos the winner will be chosen at
random and we will announce the winner
in in a video we're giving away a couple
more until the end of the year so be
sure to enter so here is the latest bit
of news that we've learned about the
century in the Thunderbolts film
specifically about his role in the film
and how exactly he gets there to start
off Sentry is going to be the main
villain of this film now comic book fans
know that Century eventually becomes a
good guy he ends up working with a lot
of different superheroes and actually
becomes somewhat of a mentor to
Spider-Man he's a really phenomenal
character and although we haven't heard
anything about casting yet Henry Cavill
is kind of a free agent now in the
superhero World he's no longer playing
DC Superman but I sure would love for
him to come over to the MCU and play
Century who is essentially kind of like
a Superman that and we would essentially
get an evil Superman in the Thunderbolts
film I do believe he's going to turn
good eventually but his origins in the
MCU seem pretty cool so far according to
The Insider account can we get some
toast that has a really great track
record with Scoops Sentry will be the
villain of the Thunderbolts and he will
be created by Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine now this is really interesting
and this is actually how it ties into
Captain America new world order it
basically has everything to do with
super soldier serum and it sounds like
this is going to somewhat stay true to
the comic Origins but with a Twist you
see in the comics Canada and the United
States kind of pulled their resources
together to start project Sentry and the
goal was not just to recreate the super
soldier serum but it was to enhance it
and not just by a little bit but over a
hundred thousand times now unfortunately
there wasn't really any oversight of
this project and it resulted in over
like a thousand different Labs who were
working on their own sub projects of the
century and then one day the meth addict
Robert Reynolds discovered one of these
Laboratories and discovered the golden
Century serum in which he consumed
gaining the power of a million exploding
Suns now once he drank the serum he
actually ended up due to the raw power
killing some of the lab's guards and his
partner this caught the attention of the
heads of the project and they were
appalled that they didn't really have
any oversight and that this happened so
they asked him if they could study him
he said yes but eventually he desired to
do greater good and actually become a
superhero and go out there and fight
villains and do good so he took on the
name Sentry and became a hero and like I
said he ended up becoming a mentor to
Spider-Man discovering that Peter Barker
was Spider-Man almost instantly after
meeting him he fought alongside the
X-Men and alongside the Fantastic Four
he's even considered an equal to Reed
Richards however he is going to be the
villain in the Thunderbolts movie and be
created by Valentina so what does this
mean well it means that Valentina and
Thunderbolt Ross because super soldier
Serum is his thing have created a golden
Century serum or something extremely
similar maybe not titled the same but
have created something like that to
create the century and once they create
him they're going to use him or at least
try to use him because remember they're
calling in the Thunderbolts to defeat
him so Valentina and Thunderbolt Ross
both created the century why would they
send the Thunderbolts to defeat him well
I'm going to assume it's somewhat like
the comics they create the century and
they try to use him and study him but he
simply breaks away and he has the power
to do so again the power of 1 million
exploding Suns that's pretty powerful so
I'm assuming he breaks away and wants to
kind of do his own thing and that pisses
off Valentina and Thunderbolt Ross so
they have to gather the Thunderbolts the
actual team to go and hunt him down and
either kill him or bring him back and I
don't think they're going to be
successful at either of those because
eventually I do think that Sentry is
going to want to do good and he's going
to join the Avengers and the Fantastic
Four and probably be a pretty big
character in secret wars in the King
Dynasty however like I mentioned the
Thunderbolts is going to connect to
Captain America 4. and the big
connection here is the super soldier
serum slash the golden Century serum now
ever since the Incredible Hulk we know
that this is Thunderbolt Ross's thing
super soldier serum and now him and
Valentina are essentially creating super
soldiers times 100
000 and we don't really know anything
about the subjects or why they are
creating these people anyways we don't
know if these subjects are volunteering
or if they're simply forcing random
people to do it I'm sure it's not
completely random I'm sure they might be
using prisoners or former war heroes who
could possibly have addictions that
could tie into the meth addiction that
Robert Reynolds has but either way this
is pretty much a no-go this is frowned
upon him this is something that Sam
Captain America is going to want to stop
this new report is also coming from the
account can we get some toast and they
say Sam is looking to assemble a new
team of Avengers to take down president
Ross in Captain America New World Order
and we now know why everything that I
just mentioned is why they are still
conducting super soldier experiments
something they probably and really
shouldn't do and I'm assuming it's
pretty shady as well like I said some of
the subjects probably aren't there by
their own will so the new Avengers team
is going to be assembled in Captain
America New World Order and here's what
the rumored team is said to be and it's
not really a rumor because we've already
been introduced to these characters
right now the new Avengers team is
supposed to be Captain America of course
Sam Wilson the New Black Panther AKA
shuri Ant-Man which means he's not going
to die in Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania Captain Marvel She-Hulk and Shang
Chi now let me know right away what you
think about this lineup in the comments
down below it's pretty hard to compare
them to the iconic original Avengers
team but what do you think of this team
now these have all been kind of
connected one way or another but I am
curious to see how characters like
Captain America and Xiang Chi get
together because I don't think there's
really any connections there besides
Wong I think Wong is going to play a
pretty big role in connecting some of
these people together in fact I think
Sam might actually seek him out or
Doctor Strange out however since Wong is
sorcerer Supreme right now and since
he's the one that's been popping up
everywhere I'm going to assume that it's
going to be him that kind of assembles
this team and helps Sam because I also
think that doctor strange is probably
with Cleo right now trying to undo an
incursion or possibly even more than one
but the question is could this team
eventually go on to take out somebody
huge like Sentry because if you think
about the whole progression of the
Thunderbolts and then Captain America
new world to order although it doesn't
seem likely just based off of the power
of Sentry it does seem like the best
option here is for the Thunderbolts to
actually capture Sentry again and for
the government to kind of control the
Sentry again and use him to fight the
new Avengers team because if you look at
this team it's got some pretty hard
hitters I'm specifically talking about
Captain Marvel and chongqi the others
are great as well don't get me wrong but
Captain Marvel is pretty op and shangshi
seemingly knows how to use those Rings
pretty well now the two of them's Powers
combined with a pure physical strength
of She-Hulk and Black Panther plus not
to mention the strength of Ant-Man when
he shrinks down and blows up the skills
of Black Panther and of course Captain
America calling all of the shots this
would be a pretty good team however can
they take on the Century essentially
Superman a man with the power of a
million exploding Sons keep in mind in
the comics nobody kind of defeats him he
actually usually defeats himself
unfortunately him being the century
brings a huge creature called the void
to Earth to always try to capture him
and the void is responsible for millions
of deaths in the comics so in the comics
in order to get the void away Sentry
agrees to have his memories of himself
erased to the point to where he has no
recollection of the Sentry at all or any
of his friends unfortunately so this
could be how they eventually defeat the
Sentry and kind of control him who knows
if the void is going to be a thing on
the MCU but the point is is that nobody
really can defeat him physically so I
think that the new Avengers team might
end up going the friend route and try to
save him instead of defeat him since the
main villain of Captain America 4 is
supposed to be Thunderbolt Ross but hey
let me know what you think about all
this new exciting news in the comments
down below and if you have a theory
about Century be sure to drop it in the
comments as well don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
theories and for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf